FLORIDA WAS AMONG THE MAJOR
STATES LATEST THIS WEEK TO DO
THAT.
SENATOR RICK SCOTT JOINS US
RIGHT NOW, REPUBLICAN SENATOR
FROM THE BEAUTIFUL STATE OF
FLORIDA.
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME.
>> NEIL DON’T YOU JUST FEEL
SORRY FOR ALL OF THESE FAMILIES
THAT ARE GOING THROUGH THIS?
ONE THEY MIGHT BE LOSING THEIR
JOBS OR  DON’T KNOW WHAT’S GOING
TO HAPPEN BUT NUMBER TWO THEY’RE
SCARED TO DEATH IF THEY TEST
POSITIVE, SO MY HEART GOES OUT
TO EVERYBODY AND IT SEEMS LIKE
WE ALL KNOW SOMEBODY THAT PASSED
AWAY, HANDS GOING TO IMPACT ALL
OF OUR FAMILIES SO MY HEART GOES
OUT TO EVERYBODY.
NEIL: DO YOU ALSO LOOK AT THIS ,
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT I GUESS IT
WAS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
GOVERNOR DESANTIS HELD OFF AS
LONG AS HE COULD ON THE STAY
AT HOME MEASURES BUT NOW YOU
HAVE THEM INFECT AND POLICING
THE BEACHES TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
DON’T GATHER IN GROUPS OF 10 OR
MORE THAT THIS COULD GET WORSE,
A LOT WORSE.
>> OH, NEIL I WAS ON THE PHONE
WITH A LOT OF BUSINESSES
YESTERDAY, AND PEOPLE ARE JUST
SCARED TO DEATH.
HERE IS THE POSITIVE.
WE, AS A COUNTRY NOW, WE ARE
TAKING DRASTIC ACTION AND WE SEE
WHAT’S GOING ON IN NEW YORK
NOW.
WE SEE THAT PEOPLE ARE DYING.
WE SEE THE GROWTH IN THE CASES
SO MY EXPERIENCE IN TALKING TO
PEOPLE ALL OVER FLORIDA ARE
PEOPLE ARE TAKING THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY NOW.
THEY ARE STAYING HOME IF THEY
CAN AND THEY ARE GETTING TESTED
IF THEY CAN.
IT’S FRUSTRATING RIGHT NOW.
WE STILL HAVE ENOUGH TESTING
SITES UP.
WE CAN GET THE RESULTS QUICKLY.
SO THE TESTING PROCESS AROUND MY
STATE AND I THINK AROUND THE
COUNTRY STILL HAS A LOT OF
WORK TO DO, BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT
TO QUARANTINE IF THEY KNOW THEY
ARE POSITIVE BUT PEOPLE ARE
WAITING 10 DAYS AS MUCH AS 10
DAYS TO GET A RESULT.
WE HAVE TO GET THIS FIXED, SO
THERE’S A LOT OF PEOPLE SCARED
WHAT’S GOING ON RIGHT NOW BUT
I’M OPTIMISTIC THAT WE’RE GOING
TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
LOOK, NEIL OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM IS A GREAT HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM.
THEY ARE GOING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO TREAT PATIENTS.
WHEN THEY DO THAT’S GOING TO
ALLEVIATE A LOT OF CONCERN
PEOPLE HAVE.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, SENATOR, YOUR
COLLEAGUE, MARCO RUBIO HAD
LOOKED AT THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
THIS AND SAID NOTHING OF FOLKS
WHO WERE SCARED TO YOUR POINT.
HE SAID WE’VE GOT UNEMPLOYED
PISSED OFF PEOPLE.
THEY CAN’T GET BENEFITS AND WHEN
THEY GET THEM THEY’RE NOT GOING
TO BE ENOUGH.
RIGHT NOW, THESE ARE THE FOLKS
WHO ARE LOOKING TO THIS CRISIS.
RIGHT NOW, CHARLIE CRIST, WHO
WAS HURT BY A BAD ECONOMY,
REPUBLICANS HE SAID MIGHT BE IN
THE SAME POSITION RIGHT NOW.
DO YOU WORRY ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, I MEAN, LOOK I’M
WORRIED ABOUT PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT POLITICS.
THIS IS ABOUT HOW DO YOU HELP
EVERY FAMILY.
MOST I’VE WENT THROUGH, LOOK I
WENT THROUGH HURRICANES, I WENT
THROUGH MASS SHOOTINGS, I WENT
THROUGH THE ZIKA CRISIS, THERE’S
ALWAYS GOING TO BE A CRISIS, AND
WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN IS PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO COME TOGETHER AND
THEY ALWAYS DO.
FAMILIES DO IT, COMMUNITIES DO
IT, CHURCHES ARE INVOLVED,
GOVERNMENT CAN BE HELPFUL.
WE’LL GET THROUGH THIS AND I
THINK THE KEY IS GOING TO BE IF
WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT WE CANNOT
GET  INFECTED.
EVERY PERSON SAYS TO THEMSELVES
I AM GOING TO NOT GET  INFECTED
AND THEN THIS WILL STOP AND
THAT’S WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN
AND THANK GOD WE HAVE HEALTHCARE
WORKERS AND PEOPLE ARE STOCKING
OUR GROCERIES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT BECAUSE THEY’RE THE ONES
MAKING SURE WE COULD ALL SURVIVE
WHILE WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO TREAT
THESE PATIENTS.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT, SENATOR SCOTT,
HOPEFULLY, THIS DOESN’T GO ON
FOREVER, SO WE’LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS HERE BUT SENATOR THANK